you are not
you are not
sir
you are not the father
maury povich may be bidding farewell to
paternity tests but there's one he'll
never forget there is one particular
show
that i that's etched in my memory
forever the daytime host just announced
he's retiring ending his talk show in
september after 31 years on the air
we've had such a good run
i thought now is the time to end it
and while the 83 year old has decades of
episodes under his belt he admitted
during an interview with good morning
america wednesday that there's one
episode in particular that stands out
one month ago vena gave birth to
fraternal twins
peyton
and tegan it's around the time vina got
pregnant she admits she slept with one
of her ex-boyfriends
and chad is desperate to find out if
he's the biological father the episode
involved a woman who wasn't sure who
fathered her twins which wasn't exactly
an uncommon occurrence on maury but when
he opened the envelope to learn the
truth the results even shocked mori when
it comes to one-month-old pagan
chad
you are the [ __ ]
and
when it comes to one-month-old peyton
chad
you are not
i say you're the father of one but not
the other
and i look at my staff and go what
and they said it's a million to one shot
according to the scientists with
fraternal twins if someone is pretty
active over 24-48 hour period you can
have two fathers
well over the years those paternity
tests proved to be ratings gold and when
et sat down with the tv personality back
in 2019 he dished on how it all came to
be
they came to me one time and they said
we have this idea
we want to do paternity tests daytime
soap operas would be doing these kinds
of themes and they would take six months
to get an answer and
play it out all year long and they said
you know we can have all this conflict
all this drama and we can have a result
within 10 or 12 minutes and the audience
that's all they're looking for as a
result and i said that's
i mean okay it's fine with me the first
time we did it i was briefed on the
story
and the producer for that particular
show said
and the result i said i don't want to
know the result i don't want to know the
result i don't want to know anything
more than my guests i don't want to
think anything more than my audience my
live audience my audience at home if i
know the answer i will skew my questions
i don't want to know anything more than
the people i'm talking to and that was
the key because i'm as surprised as they
are
on monday maury addressed his retirement
in a statement to et writing that he's
proud of the run before joking quote as
i occasionally tell my guests on maury
enough already more than anything else i
think laura i'm going to miss
i'm going to miss the storytelling
whether i've whatever i've done all
these years i've always said that i'm
nothing more than a storyteller so i'll
miss that
but personally i'm going to miss the
crew and the staff
as for the legacy he hopes the show
leaves behind here's what he told gma
more than anything else he was
compassionate
to the people who told their stories all
these years and that he could always uh
they they could
they could unwind their burden with him
and i think more than anything else
according to my guest i think i've lived
up to it and that's all i care about
[Music]